Даніель Лихвенко почувається обманутою.
19-річна студентка-юристка з України кілька тижнів
пропрацювала на фермі під Ганновером.
Збирала полуниці.
- Я відчуваю, що мене повністю оббрехали, тому що
в юридичних документах сказано, що я маю
працювати 6 годин, що я буду за це отримувати 9,19 (євро) кожної години.
Але насправді виявилося, що ми працювали на вироблення продукції.
Ми збирали кілограми і за це отримували 60 центів за кілограм.
А ще працювали без вихідних і це могло сягати 14-ти годин на день.
Тепер дівчина переїхала до друзів у Кельн.
Ми їдемо на ферму, якою вже понад 20 років керує Пеер Зандер.
- У нас є постійні працівники з Польщі та Румунії, які працюють у нас цілий рік.
Серед працівників - і 250 українських сезонних робітників.
Найняли їх за допомогою агентства у Києві, яке,
власне, й організовує дозволи на роботу.
- Лише з робочою візою та за згодою Федерального агентства зайнятості
українські студенти можуть приїхати на сезонні роботи.
У Німеччині з сезонними робітниками укладають контракти,
які регулюють заробітну плату та тривалість робочого дня.
Із отриманих грошей 6 євро на день
українці сплачують за проживання.
Є безкоштовний інтернет, можливість приготувати собі їжу й купити продукти.
А ось це - для скарг.
- У цю скриньку можна також анонімні скарги кидати.
Хоча великої кількості нарікань я поки не отримував.
Наскільки серйозно розглядають скарги сезонних робітників,
перевірити складно. Зокрема ще й тому, що
відпрацьовані години ніде не фіксуються.
Це - причина найбільших нарікань і порушень.
Це має змінитися -
такий нещодавній вердикт Європейського суду з прав людини.
Цього ж вимагають і профспілки.
- У зв’язку з, наприклад, новим законодавством ЄС
щодо обов’язкової фіксації тривалості робочого дня
ми сподіваємося, що можна буде досягти
кращого дотримання вимог справедливої оплати.
Документувати тривалість робочого часу
для роботодавця означає більше бюрократії.
Але вони теж прагнуть уникати конфліктів із робітниками.
- Переважноми вживаємо заходів для того, щоб в разі чого
люди на місці зв’язувалися з бригадирами
і все одразу вирішувалося.
Проте в випадку Даніель Лихвенко цього не сталося.
Тепер вона консультується з юристом.